No.
Komputery kwantowe są bardzo wrażliwe na szum –
zakłócenia powodujące błędy
w ich obliczeniach, ale nowe badania pokazują,
że zaszumione komputery kwantowe IBM dorównują dokładnym metodom klasycznym
w weryfikowalnych reżimach i przewyższają zaawansowane klasyczne
metody aproksymacji zarówno w weryfikowalnych,
jak i niezweryfikowalnych reżimach
w ramach wymagającego eksperymentu symulacyjnego.
Jak im się to udało? Użyli specjalnej techniki
do radzenia sobie z szumem
w systemach kwantowych – nazywa się to mitygacją błędów.
Dzięki technice mitygacji błędów
zastosowanej w tym eksperymencie uruchamiamy nasze obliczenia
i stopniowo zwiększamy poziom szumu.
Następnie ekstrapolujemy z powrotem do zerowego poziomu szumu.
Ta praca przybliża nas o krok do użytecznych obliczeń kwantowych –
my